ціни сигнал тривоги
мишкам до жованки на донеччині скільки
ясусі гімн озу стригти дісталося я
приїхав і представник та управління
верховного комісара він праворуч
біженців консультант правових катувати та
Допомагати про задоволення це було все
нас навіть повертав, а там вже і ми тут була
повністю закрити і вони до нас за ним та
нікуди-нікуди ціле жування розтушоване
так дзвони siri зоні голос тут було плисти
до тисячі миша кінців нині втратила кілька
100 людей зводять кінсей скинь team та
багато миша conti чути на адже у замку
живуть у своїх на пі схвильованих
пляшках ще не травня вони світлі вони
вивели вони дров буржуйки на прокаті
підвал потрібний для цієї миші
наприкінці силища вимагатимуть миру переговори
лідерів норманської четвірки на прокиньті
жовтня
дали шанс на ворога лівани ситуації на
донбасі тагіл берліні президента
Франції Росії України та канцлер окупант n
будинки влади пастельну розруб q дорожні
карти
реалізації мінських у ось довелося
засіки проза поліцейську
місію б с е
протеза вдалося вирубати і в ж а віктора
кубинських воріт від міністра
закордонних праворуч нормандською четвіркою
докладно учасника пари мовано
розкривають у team прогресу зі шкіри мало
але ж ініціатор із уст річі міністр
закордонних порівняємо і чини франк-вальтер
штайнмайєр
напружуються бойових надій і відсікай
чіткого сигналу гідру see the україни
провід вниз до 3 мм від осі мінських у
ось на тому місці в українських колегів же
заявивши до молодості з Росії і німа
нас зустрічі учні
мтс в лоб linking місяцем обговоріть
гуманітарні харчування сильно не за
ручники
і доступ даних просто вийти в
міжнародного комітету червоного
христа просто первинності про позиції до
його то Москви
раніше вражало і експерти крем
призначав іван і на лікарі погода тебе
включить і в дорожню карту ще пункт
дару оружия чи то висновки не весь до раніше
на поки що проросійські бойовики і треба
чи продовжила там і обстріли, а буду
намагайся нових вчинок витка його поки
школі так і на мага юті думова тиса
ведмедик mty жуйка
за
знають і прогадаєте 5 звук і обстрілявши
надходило зустрічаю чарівнику наш горілка
завершення винні